- First of all, I want to
say welcome to everyone
for attending our followup salon
after Carlo Rovelli's
excellent talk yesterday,
discussing the intricacies
of causes and effects.
And so today we're gonna have
sort of a moderated
discussion with a open Q and A
at the end of it,
and it is my absolute
pleasure to introduce to you
the interlocutor for today.
And that is Eric Winsburg,
who is a philosopher of science
and works on philosophy of physics a lot
and has worked in particular
on models, inferences,
drawing inferences from modeling
and conceptual frameworks.
He's an expert and he's looked
at many kinds of models.
So he's extremely
well-known for his work on
the nature of simulations
and numerical simulations
with applications particularly
to one of the most vexing
problems of our times,
which is the climate problem.
So the modeling of climate
and what the issues are
with modeling a complex system like that,
which is a nonlinear complex system.
So that is sort of his expertise.
And in general, as I mentioned,
he looks at conceptual frameworks
and currently he is looking at COVID-19.
And isn't that right Eric?
- Yeah, I've been looking at some
of the modeling stuff with
Carlo Rovelli (indistinct).
- So, and of course, Carlo
Rovelli needs no introduction,
philosopher of physics physicist
and a claimed writer who
writes and is invested deeply
in sort of the public
understanding of science.
So I'm absolutely delighted
to give the floor over
to the two of you.
So Eric, did you, you had
a few slides with which--
- Yeah, I thought I
would just kind of review
that some of the key points of the talk
and along the way
raise where I thought the
most interesting points
for discussing some questions
were kind of integrate
some of the questions
that people asked yesterday
and sort of maybe integrate them
with my way of thinking about them,
rephrase them in my way
of thinking about them.
Okay, so let me share my PowerPoint here.
Okay, great, so this is
just a Carlos title,,
"What is a cause and why has
it happened before the effect?"
And so just to kind of remind people
of what the basic
situation is here, right?
The Laws of physics
don't seem to privilege
a basic direction in time,
but there's sort of three,
at least three maybe four,
key aspects of ordinary experience,
that do seem to privilege
a direction of time.
One is what you might just think of
as the ordinary physical
asymmetry and time, right?
We see ice melting and our cocktail glass
and the water cooling as that happens.
We don't see the water
spontaneously warming
and injecting ice cubes,
eggs break but they don't unbreak, right?
So we just see there
are lots of phenomenon
that we see in the world
that are time asymmetric.
The second one is that I know
a lot more about the past
than I knew about the future.
And I knew it with greater ease.
If I wanna know what the weather in Tampa
was on February 28th, 1954,
I can look at an old
edition of the Tampa times,
but if I wanna know, what's
gonna be February 28th, 2021,
I need to make a forecast
using basic physics.
And if I wanna know what it's
gonna be February 28th, 2054,
I'm just out of luck.
There's no way I'm gonna know that.
The third and I'm gonna
try to say more carefully
what this means is I think
this one's hard to stay.
I can influence the
future, but not the past.
That's kind of the key thing
that Carlos talk was about.
But as I say, I don't
wanna kind of point out
some exactly clear what
we mean when we say that.
And then there's actually
kind of a fourth asymmetric
people sometimes talk about.
And that's that I sometimes seem to care
more about my future
self than my past self.
If you ask people, would you rather
have had a headache yesterday
or have one tomorrow,
most people would say,
yes, I'd rather have it out of the way,
I'd rather have a headache
yesterday than tomorrow,
it's better to have bad
things be in the past
and it's better to have
good things in the future.
So I seem to care more
about my future self
than my past self.
So those are kind of a four
features of ordinary experience
their time asymmetric
and all of them that,
pose it a little bit of a puzzle,
given that the laws of physics themselves
are time symmetric.
Okay, so what do we mean when we say
that the laws of physics
are time symmetric?
Well, one way to think about it,
is by thinking about
physics as describing,
as living in kind of a state space.
So the easiest way to think about this
is if we just and everything I'm gonna say
I'm gonna assume kind of a
really simple classical physics
picture of the world but
nothing really hinges on that.
It just kind of makes
it a little bit simpler.
So if you think of a box of gas
with a bunch of particles bouncing around,
you can sort of
mathematically represent that
if there's end particles bouncing around
and each particle has three
numbers that pick up position
and three numbers that pick out velocity,
then a six to the end dimensional space
kind of one point in that
completely describes right.
Completely described that system.
And what it is to say
that the laws of physics
are time symmetric,
is to say that what the laws really do,
is they pick out allowable
path through that space space.
And to say that they're time symmetric,
it's just to say that,
any time the laws allow
a path going this way,
they allow the fact same pathway
in the opposite direction.
There's some slight infelicities in that
but none that really matter, right?
Okay, so, as Carlo pointed out,
this has just been a
feature of physical laws
pretty much since Newton.
We have lots of different theories
of what the physical world is like.
They all seem to have this feature,
they all seem to be time symmetric.
They all seem to say,
if something can happen,
at the microscopic level, then
it's time reverse can happen.
That just seems to be kind
of a non-starter to deny that
for the last 400 years,
after we've been coming up
with theories of physics.
Okay, again, right, can I do this?
Yeah, so we know, that
our ordinary experience.
It's just a little YouTube
video I found yesterday, right?
This is the ad for a company
that allows you to reverse your video.
And when we see things
happening right backwards
they strike us as strange, right?
That's just we immediately
recognize that as something
that does not happen in an
ordinary experience, okay?
So where does that come from?
We know it can't come
from the laws of physics.
So if it comes from physics,
it's gotta come from somewhere else.
And the answer is usually
that it comes from something to do
with the initial conditions, right?
'Cause that's all there,
that's all physics has
and has laws, and it has
an initial conditions.
And once you get the laws
of initial traditions,
physics basically says,
you've picked up the whole world for me.
Okay, but there's kind of
a third thing that we need.
And that's Carlo mentioned
this a lot yesterday.
That's this idea that we
need a macro partition,
that is, we need a way of carving up
the possible way the world could
be at the microscopic level
into ways that are
discernible to us, right?
So that, obviously there's lots
that you can make very small changes
in the microscopic physics of the world
that I'm looking at right now,
and I wouldn't notice them.
So if you kind of carve over the world up
into the little bits of microscopic
ways the world could be,
and then put them into little bundles
of ones that are indiscernible to me,
you get this macro partition.
And it turns out that the laws of physics
basically bang you around
and you're as a kind of
more or less random law.
And in the macro partition,
the initial state that
the universe started in
is a very, very small one.
Then that kind of maybe
you can explain why,
as the laws of physics, bang us around
in this macro partition,
we go from smaller ones to bigger ones,
and our brains are wired, right?
When we see the egg reassembling itself,
our brain is saying, wait a minute,
wait a minute, wait a minute,
you've moved from a big area
in the macro pick partition,
to a small volume, sorry,
volume in the macro partition,
and that ain't right, right?
And that strikes us as bizarre,
and we think that's weird
and it's not part of
our ordinary experience,
but with these two things together,
these three things together, right?
Some laws of physics and initial
condition that we start in
and this macro partition
hopefully can explain, right?
And this, I think is
pretty uncontroversial
that can explain why eggs break
but they don't reassemble,
why ice smelts but it doesn't
spontaneously form, et cetera.
Okay, good, so that explains eggs,
but what about the weather report?
Why do we have records of the past,
but not records of the future?
And I used to be kind of
a little bit of a skeptic
about whether this story could work.
But it's actually Carlos paper
that I read just a few months ago,
I forgot what the title was.
The one we read it with
the San Diego reading grim.
It's a really, really nice paper,
and he really nicely explains,
how the statistical mechanical
assymetry I just talked about
gives you the temporary
assymetry of records.
And the idea is just this, right?
That like, if you have nice, smooth,
sort of low entropy devices
kind of sitting here, right?
Like a nice calm pond
and you throw some other
sort of low entropy thing
and they collide with each other,
you get a disturbing sense
that they kind of can persist for awhile.
And here is just,
I'm not doing this just
because a really nice paper,
I think he lays out all the details
of this in a way that I actually
found rather convincing,
even though I sort of maybe previously
been a little bit of a skeptic of that.
Okay, so that's how we get
out of just the asymmetry
in the initial conditions,
plus this macro position,
that's how we get maybe,
and I've become more and
more condensed to this,
that's how we get the existence
of records about the past
but no records of the future.
Okay, so that seems nice, right?
Even though the laws of
physics are time reversible,
a nice course graining on
the initial conditions,
would explain why we
have records of the past
but not the future.
Okay, but notice if we
want both of these things,
either one of them really,
if we want to explain
why eggs don't unbreak,
and we wanna explain why are the records,
we need not just the right
laws and the right core screen,
we need a harmony between
the dynamical laws
and the course graining that
does all the work, right?
Some law that initial conditions
with different course
grainings won't forget,
that's for my breaking
and some course grainings
won't prevent extra when
breaking with different laws.
Okay, and fundamental physics
is completely ignorant
of the course graining, right?
The course graining is not a
feature of fundamental physics.
So where does the course
graining come from?
Well, it comes from us, right?
And so here I wanna remind
people of a question
that Brian Campbell Smith asked yesterday,
he asked, "I hear you
saying biology and culture
require low entropy macro valuables,
this is how, why, where we developed,
could it be instead that
we are more responsible
for the low-entropy
macroscopic properties we use,
than a consequences.
Could it be that we humans
course frame the world
in ways that parceled
up in low entropy ways?
And 'cause the answer was
well yes, both, right?
And we do course graining,
but not by choice.
So like choice of ours of course graining,
it's something about the basic
way that we're put together.
I mean, here's my way of
thinking about it, right?
It's hard to imagine,
I would think creatures
who stabilizing properties
and information processing abilities
and reproductive abilities, et cetera,
are realized with the kind of biochemistry
and the kind of neuro physics
and the kind of, the basic kind of way
in which we're engineered,
it's hard to imagine creatures like us
who didn't have our course graining.
So if the direction of
time is tied to causation
and causation is tied to agency,
we might wanna ask like
what is required for agency,
and is agency fundamentally
type our course graining?
And there are a couple of
questions we could ask there
that I think are really interesting.
One is like, could there be
agents whose course graining
as such that what we call the
final state of the universe,
is very low entropy to them,
and therefore are kind of zooming bias
and the opposite causal direction,
could really never see these guys, right?
But it's not possible, right?
Or is it just impossible
to imagine creatures
who do anything remotely
like information processing
and reproduction and whatever else
we would make them creatures,
without having that same
course graining as us?
That's I think something
that's sort of probably
hard to answer, but financial
thing to speculate about,
and this is a pick another question
that I was wondering about
during Carlos talk yesterday.
So it's really, I thought
about this question
of where course graining
comes wrong for a long time
and there should have two different ways
of thinking about it, right?
What is it about us that course graining?
So if you take like an
introductory statistical mechanics
but right, it'll say I want
the course graining is,
say something like it's a
course graining of the universe
gets a States that are equal
with respect to certain
microscopic variables,
like, and usually they munch
things like temperature
and pressure, magnetization,
things like that.
Those are usually the
macroscopic variables
that we think of as course graining,
when we're doing physics rather
than like philosophy or whatever.
So what I was wondering about is
does my course graining come
from my observational capacities?
Or does it come from my
interventional capacities?
Or is it some complicated
mixture of the two?
And if it fundamentally involves
my interventional capacities,
is there something a little bit circular
about the whole story now?
So, I tend to think of like,
what the history of statistical
mechanics is, right?
It starts with thermodynamics,
and thermodynamic was a control theory.
Thermodynamics was the theory which said,
"Here are the things that
if you wanna be an engineer
that's building steam engines,
here are the things you can do.
Here are the kinds of interventions
that you can make in the world.
And here are the ones that
are impossible, right?
But they're impossible
not because microphysics
for this though,
they're impossible because
of the kind of creature
that you are, with big fat fingers.
And so, it's almost
sometimes I think like,
the course graining comes not just from
what I can discern observationally,
but what causal handles
I have on the world.
If that's right, my spire
sense starts to tingle now
that maybe something
circular is going on here.
And I'm not really sure
if I think that or not
but I'd like to explore that idea
at least hear Carlos story
about why that shouldn't be a worry, okay.
- Eric I have a quick question.
- Yes please.
- So in this particular
case, are you, I mean
is this a claim that evolution
maybe select for this?
So there's like a thermodynamic selection,
I mean, are you--
- Well, the idea is this is,
let's go back to this book
to Maxwell's Demon, right?
So Maxwell, James Clerk Maxwell,
one of the founders of
Cisco gangs pointed out,
that if you had a little
guy who was small enough,
that he could see every
little bouncing particle
in a box of gas and you can
open and close a shadow.
In response to them he could cause
anti-thermodynamic
behavior to happen, okay?
So the fact that we can't bring
about anti-thermodynamic behavior
has to do with the difference
between us and Maxwell's Demon
and that difference is
something like that,
my fingers are too fat,
I can't operate little
shutters that small.
- It's fast enough.
- it's fast enough,
quickly enough, responsively
enough to micro conditions.
What my interventions on the world are,
they're brooder and coarser than that.
And that's kind of what picks
out the course graining,
and it's kind of, Carlo
uses the expression
subtle dance between two
things a lot yesterday.
And I feel like there's
something going on in here
in the macro partition
which is people often talk about it being
how to do with our
observational capacities.
But I think it's kind of
the result of a subtle dance
between our observational and
our interventional capacities.
And I kind of like, see if
we could talk about that
a little bit at some point today,
'cause I think it's kind of interesting.
Okay, another thing that I
kind of would certainly noticed
in the talk yesterday is that Carlo,
you used a couple of different,
quite different
characterizations of agency.
Early in the talk, you talked about agency
as just kind of anything
counts as an agent.
If I can bracket it off,
and it sort of affects what's
an otherwise closed system.
So if I can divide the
universe into two halves
and consider one half of it closed,
and then something comes
from over in this half
and comes in and bounces
at it like meteorite
or something like that,
that can count as agency.
But I guess I feel like
that's not quite right.
And I feel like later in the talk,
you said things that
I think are more right
about what agency is.
Agents are the kinds of people, sorry.
Agents are the kinds of entities
that collect information,
deliberate about what they
want the future to be like,
and, move themselves around in
the world some way or other,
so as to bring about
things that they prefer.
- So there's intentionality?
- There's some intentionality,
there's some information processing,
there's some deliberation,
there's stuff like that.
So, and one way of I've
been thinking about
why I don't think that the
first characterization of agency
works as, we do talk about sort of,
meteorites coming in and causing craters.
We do this, but I think that's parasitic
on the causal ordering
that we've already imposed
on the world that comes from
our deliberation agency.
I don't think if microscopic
Laplas and demons,
came to our world and
there were no people in it,
they wouldn't think
that incoming meteorites
and outgoing volcanic eruptions
were interestingly different.
There be no asymmetry there,
the asymmetry I think only comes
when we have deliberative
agents, causal asymmetry, right?
I think only happens when
we have deliberate agents,
where if not, I've come
to like to hear more about
why I shouldn't think that,
because that's my inclination.
Okay, so what is agency?
To me agency is fundamentally
tied to deliberation
which means it's tied to
information gathering,
information processing,
it's tied to preferences
and it's tied to integrating
all those abilities
so as to bring about preferences.
Okay, so when I talk
about the third asymmetry
at the beginning, I said it's
that we can change the future
but not the past, but
that's of course wrong.
We've known sort of since data Hume
that well, we have to understand agency
in harmony with determinism, right?
We have to understand
that it's possible to have
agentional beings in a deterministic world
and in the deterministic world,
I can't change the future anymore
than I can change the past.
But I still deliberate about it.
And that's a puzzling fact,
it's a puzzling fact once
it's when you have to swallow.
So it's not that causes precede effects.
That's a reasonable first
pass at what the asymmetry is,
but I don't think it's
exactly what the asymmetry is.
I think asymmetry is that
it's not that we can influence
the future, but not the past.
So the problem with the
first characterization
is it's non-agentional,
and there's no non-agentional
characterization
of the third asymmetry.
The problem with the
second characterization
is it doesn't respect, the
insights of compatibilism,
that we have to understand deliberation
alongside determinism.
So I think that the real
third asymmetry is this,
it's that we on pain of
insanity, we deliberate about
how we wanna make the
world be in the future.
We do not deliberate about
how we want the world to be in the past,
when we make decisions, okay?
If you saw someone standing at a lever,
trying to decide whether to put the lever
to the right or to the left,
and you said, what are you doing?
What are you trying to figure out?
What are you deciding on the basis of?
And the person said,
I want the world to be in such
and such a way in the future.
And I'm trying to figure out
which side this lever goes
is more likely to bring
about the future that I want.
We'd say, yeah, that's cool.
That's a normal thing, your normal person.
If they said that about the past
we call them men with white coats.
Wow, I think that's the asymmetry.
That's what you price is
called the temporal asymmetry
of disjunctive deliberation.
Nice, fancy word for that.
So agency, I'm putting
up the trolley problem,
They're not, cause I'm gonna
start talking about ethics.
But here's the famous Phillip
a foot trolley problem.
Should I push the fat man
in front of the trolley
to save the five people?
That's a perfectly sensible question.
But should we push the fat
man on the trolley to prevent,
so maybe you tell me,
hey you know what Eric,
someone is predicting,
whether you're gonna push
the fat man under the tracks.
And if he predicts that you're
gonna push him on the tracks,
he's gonna kill five people.
You're just your mind recoils
at this whole scenario.
And you ended up in a new comes paradox
and you end up in all
kinds of strange things
because we just think it's absurd,
when we're thinking of
ourselves as agents,
when we're deliberating
about what actions to take,
we think it's absurd to worry about
how they're gonna make the past be okay?
Now it's absolutely right that
you can solve this problem.
This problem goes away.
This problem stops being a problem.
It stops being a puzzle.
If you can explain the sense
in which the future is open
and the past is closed.
Because if the past is closed,
and of course I don't have deliberate
about how to change it.
Okay, but here's the
$64,000 question I think
about yesterday's talk.
Does the existence of records
sufficiently close the past
and open the future
to explain the sense of why
it's exceeding to deliberate
about changing the past?
And I see Carlo shaking
his hat, which worries me,
because I think that's what we need.
If we really wanna understand,
if we really wanna solve this
the main puzzle of asymmetry
about causation, is this,
why do I not deliberate about
how I want the past to be?
And so does the existence of records
as based to doing the slide?
Does the existence of records
cure the relevant notions
of the past and future being
respectively closed and open?
Okay, and there were, I
think a couple of questions
from the audience yesterday
that were pressing on that.
So Peter Morgan asked,
my zoom thing gets up in
the way of here we go.
The past is only fixed in
so far as traces persist.
Is it only at the creation
of traces is relatively fast.
The decay of traces is slower,
that if we burn evidence is gone.
So the worry here is that
there are lots of things
about the past, that we
don't have traces, like.
There's a lot about the past that's open.
Why do make deliberate about
how to make that different.
And so, if two people are
observing the same traces,
might make different
inferences about the past.
We assume that one is
right, the other is wrong.
Okay, but if the fact about,
if the closeness of of the past
is about the inferences
I can make her records,
some weird is going on.
That's shaky notion of close.
It's a great epistemic notion
of the past being closed.
And it might be closed
for me and open for you.
So you might think it's insane for me
to deliberate how the past is
to me, because you believe,
like maybe I'm trying to kill baby Hitler.
And you think you have a
picture of baby Hitler,
so you think I'm insane.
And I said, no, that picture
of baby Hitler is blurry.
I think maybe the past about
whether there's a baby
Hitler is still open or not.
I mean, that seems like a
weird thing for the insanity
of me trying to bring it
about not by time travel,
but just by intervening on the present,
trying to kill baby Hitler.
Whether that's insane or not,
depending on whether the picture
of baby Hitler is blurry
or not, seems weird.
Okay, I think I'm
getting close to the end.
Yeah, so the existence of records
doesn't seem like it's
enough to prevent me
from deliberating about
how I want the past to be
both because records are limited
and because records are uncertain.
Okay, so thanks, Carlo, thanks
for your talk yesterday.
It's super interesting,
super thought provoking.
Those are some of my some of my questions.
- Thank you, Eric, that was fantastic.
Love your slides.
Wonderful, and I think we
are waiting to hear back
from Carlo about, I think a lot
of intriguing questions
that you have raised.
And I think some of these
questions are quite profound,
I have to say.
So I'm really looking forward
to what Carlo has to respond.
- Thank you Priya and thank you Eric.
I have been taking notes
furiously while you were talking.
Let me anticipate a couple of things
before trying to answer,
first of all, very happy
of what you have done.
These are subtle issues, of course.
And I often find myself discussing
with people that have a lot
of different assumptions
and it's difficult to start
organizing the common ground,
that's not the case at all in
what I heard you saying now.
I mean, I know a little bit of your work.
Well, I think I agree
with everything you say.
I mean, we are on the same ground.
We agree on the problems.
We agree on the situation.
So I'm entirely with you with everything.
And you have raised two problems.
In fact, not really to challenge us,
but to point in which you say, wait,
there seem to be missing something here
and they are both crucial.
I think I have some
understanding about both
and I'm happy to try it on you.
And I think we do have sufficient ground,
maybe not in a half an hour
if we had a couple of days
and to our chair, maybe a Blackboard,
I think we could totally
communicate on that.
Let me try it.
And I'm hesitant of doing both,
because the second is more
interesting in a sense.
- Yeah, I think the second
is definitely more interesting, yeah.
- But let me say
something about the first,
and then you tell me if
you wanna stay on that
or go on the first.
So the first one was about
a possible circularity in,
let me put it in a little
bit over sketchy manner.
In the definition of a thermodynamics
the definition of microscopic quantities,
what are the microscopic quantities
that somehow in terms
of which we make sense
of reversibility and irreversibility.
And I am 100% with you, that the clarity
in about thermodynamics is
about how we manipulate things.
And in spite of, I'm 100% with you
that in spite of a huge literature
on that diverse position,
Maxwell had it clear.
Namely, thermodynamics is
about a thermodynamic system
on which we do something.
And we'll find a number
of things we are doing.
And thermodynamic seem to tell us,
what happened if I do this,
what happened if I do that,
there's a notion of many portability.
Which is the one that
defines the course graining,
because the microscopic
quantities are the ones
so which I intervene or not.
This brings complete clarity
to the structure of thermodynamic itself.
What is missing is not
anything related to myself.
What is missing is an all right.
So who is the manipulator?
And how do we think in
terms of manipulator
if we wanna make a step further
and say, well I'm a naturalist,
I don't think there are,
demons outside nature
or us outside nature,
but there're natural systems
that are us manipulating
and demons are not pro-systems.
Nowadays in the laboratories,
you can do little Maxwell
demon syncs with molecules,
and it is another system.
So then one possibility
is just to take the notion
of a manipulation as primitive
or in another just try
to see how it concretely
it's realized it by the
manipulator as a physical system.
And I think that here, there
is a step that we can make.
And I've been insisting on that step.
Namely, we don't need manipulation,
we may have a simpler,
a more wider way of saying
exactly the same thing.
Namely, instead of
thinking thermodynamics,
if I do this, that's what happened.
We can see, and it's equally,
if there is an external system
that happened to interact in this way,
that's what gonna happen.
If so, what the term
means, the course graining,
it's an actual dynamical interaction
between the system and the
manipulator, the observer.
In other words, as a naturalist,
I wanna think of both of them
as described in physical terms.
And again, as you did
forget one, two mechanics
everything that is classical.
So if you want, there's a Hamiltonian,
Hamiltonian has an interaction terms.
This interaction term is an
interaction with some variables
of the system, not all of them.
Good, it is, that Hamiltonian
picks up some variables,
and to the extent in which
I'm describing the interaction
with the system, with something else,
the observer, that only
interact with that Hamiltonian
with that variable.
What happens is well described
with the thermodynamics
with those course graining.
So I've not--
- Yeah, that seems good.
I mean, you can just
describe what is the coupling
between me,
- Exactly.
- How their system, then you don't really
have to think that much about
what my interventions are.
Obviously my interventions
are gonna be parasitic,
I want my couplings are.
- Exactly, and this allows us.
So the price of this is that
we don't have enough priority,
thermodynamic dependent on
which system is interacting out.
Fine, I buy that, and I
don't think at this point
there's any circularity that's--
- That's pretty satisfying to
me, yeah, okay, let's move on.
Yeah, let's move, Let's I think
take the second question--
- The thing with the second question
which is the interesting one
is about agency and deliberation.
And look, I follow
carefully what you're saying
and agree with everything.
At some point you say, wait a minute
what do you mean by agent?
And at this point,
we don't wanna go into any
issue of names, of course.
It is a fact that we use agent
to indicate different things.
And there is, so we can
say agent one, agent two,
agent three to whatever.
I mean, we can get
different names to things.
So there's one definition
of agent, which is too wild.
It's not the one you like,
but it can be found in the
literature, which is very weak.
I'll go into the next one.
I'll go into the other one in a moment.
But the weak one is simply,
it depends on, I did still,
it depends on an approximate
description of a situation.
So it depends on certain
number of variables
which are related by some
relations between them,
for instance, microscopic,
for instance the solar system
dynamics, Newtonian dynamics.
And I wanna call agents everything,
which is exogenous to that
and interact with that
at sometime at some point.
- So just really quick, I
mean, you're absolutely right.
That nothing hangs on what
the dictionary definition
of agent is or anything like that.
But what hangs on is, which
notion should the agency
on your pens temporarily asymmetry, right?
- Yeah, its similar, its
committed than this is,
and then you're saying, wait a minute.
When we talk about agency that,
when temporal symmetry
comes in, there's more,
there's a notion of deliberation, okay.
Now there's no doubt that
there are very special agent
that deliberate, okay.
Even those are very different kinds
because the thermostat of my apartment
fits quite many of the
characterization of deliberate
that you gave, the
Rover, which is on Mars,
which independently decides that,
there is a sandstorm arriving,
so it shuts itself down.
It has a purpose, which
is to preserve itself,
which is written in its software.
So it's a deliberate or
in some sense, why...
And in fact, the Rover
on Mars is a good example
because sometimes it decides by itself,
sometimes it doesn't because
we go over make from,
and we use this language regularly, okay?
Take away freedom and now we control it.
No, let it decide by itself, okay?
We do understand exactly the
physics of the Rover on Mars.
We pretend to at least be
able to understand that,
we might be, and this
is a huge can of worms,
but I think we might take the stance
that we could use exactly the same logic
for understanding humans.
Namely, a lot of things
happen in our mind.
Some of this we describe as deliberation
the same ones as we use deliberation.
Now let me get, let me
zoom into the point.
What is it in the physics of those systems
that we call agent that
specifically has to do
with the difference between
the past and the future?
And I think is nothing to
do directly with traces
is a different story.
And it is the factor that it's
the same logic as the traces
but there's a very different story.
So is the fact that there's a system
that have the characteristics
that they can be fully
described in some approximation.
Okay, so these regarding something
which we might wanna change,
but in this approximation, the
history in this approximation
can be the same in the past
and different in the future.
So this is why because
of second thermodynamic,
because they are--
- Can you run that last plane
by real quick, one more time.
I didn't quite catch that
I don't think, it's that--
- I wanna call agent in some
intermediate sense between--
- Yeah, that's fine.
So we're talking about the Rover on Mars
and the claim was just that--
- As a system that has internal
behaviors, somehow which--
- I want some approximation.
So it's a course graining of the Rover
into it's causally relevant
variables or whatever, yeah.
- In this approximation,
I have information about its dynamics.
I can predict this dynamic.
But at some point my prediction allows
a splitting over the future,
but not over the past.
- Yeah, why now, where
does that come from?
- I wanna claim that--
- Yeah why is that?
- Yeah, that to my second paper
not the one who traces the one on agency.
I wanna claim that precisely
in a similar manner
in which the second law of thermodynamics
plus system separations plus
long-term realization time,
naturally to do some spaces
in exactly the same technique,
this happens, this kind of things happen.
And if you wanna think how,
you've microscopical degrees
of freedom that you don't know,
but if they can act on
macroscopic degrees of freedom,
you don't know which one
they're gonna happen.
So that's a thermodynamic description
of a split of a micro
evolution in the future.
- I said, just really quick.
So David Albert's story,
goes, first I get records,
and then I leave leverage records
into an open future and a closed past.
You're not doing that.
You're getting your
records and open future...
sorry, let me rephrase
that, in David's story,
you first to get records
that gets you an open future,
and that explains the asymmetry
in my deliberative capacities.
You just wanna tell a similar story
that underpins them
independently, is that right?
Okay.
- Yes, and the reason--
- I didn't get that
yesterday at all, okay, good.
- And the reason is exactly the one
that you were mentioning.
Namely, I spent a long
time telling myself,
look, we have record therefore
we have have the past
or the future open, but it doesn't work.
I mean, and its too weak
for the same reasons
that you were saying for the full records.
If we had full records,
perhaps this could work,
but we don't have full records.
So it's exactly the same story.
I mean, I don't have a
picture of Hitler young.
So does it mean that I
can deliberate about, no,
this should be something else
that generates the systems,
that allows the system
that we call agents, and
on what can it be granted?
I mean, if not from something
extra natural comes in,
all you on the second
law of thermodynamics.
And I think that in my second
paper, I tried to model that.
So deliberation is just
one particular case.
Deliberation is something that happens.
Let me say one thing about deliberation.
Either we can open up exactly
the mechanism of deliberation.
I can work up exactly the mechanisms
of my thermoset when it decides too, okay?
And then I realized that
the time orientation is fake
it doesn't really, I mean,
it's really time symmetric.
Or there's a deliberation
and I treat it as free, Okay?
Which I can, because we
always do it in life.
This is allowed by the
second principle dynamics
not always allowed, but it's implemented
at the second piece of thermodynamics
precisely because if you
have system segregation,
when energy goes from the hot to the cold,
the cold can have a macroscopic variables
that now evolves differently.
So this is the information that goes
from entropy to microscopic.
So in other words, I see the problems
that you're pointing out.
And I think that a careful
sort of physicist discussion
of how is it possible that
there are this deciding systems.
So what happened for
real in a physical system
that we naturally describe as a decider,
clarifies that is nothing else
that standard thermodynamics
that indeed put the system
in those system are facts
that we naturally described them
as what happened inside then
affect the future not the past.
Once this system existed,
the rest is psychology.
So now we have a one of this system
and now we wanna decide the past,
and now we with aims with the desires,
we have an evolution, we have
information, we have language,
but that's, once you
have opened up the fact
that there are a system
that can determine the
future not the past,
then you have to post to
understand how a human beings
works is a much bigger problem.
- Okay, yeah, no, I love
to that the details of that
I just had to take a look at
that paper, have a look at it.
- But, while you were talking,
I was, in fact not only agreeing with you,
but recognizing the same
parceling I went to,
I had a lot of discussion
with David Albert,
you were mentioning.
And, yes of course the
existence of the past
of traces is a major reason
for us to consider the future,
fixing it, but there's
not sufficient asymmetry
for considering the possibility
that we can act on the
future in the sense.
So we need to restart again
from the second principle
dynamics and build understanding
that, so I agree with you.
- At this point, I have this
question maybe (indistinct)
that I would like to hear both of you.
So how do we reconcile
this with this whole idea
of the sum over histories for going from,
so you can go from the past to the present
and the present to the future
and in sort of Finemen's
idea of the sort of,
some over all these possible histories.
I mean, is that just then
a natural way to link?
I mean, it's time embedded in this,
or is this just a way to
marginalize over probabilities
to distinguish it from sort
of a deterministic art?
I mean, is time intrinsic to this?
So this is something that
I'm trying to understand,
like, it may be a naive question
but I'd like to hear your take on that.
- You wanna start Eric or should I--
- Well so, I mean, when people ask
whether the time is intrinsic,
that when just one thing like
one wants to be super clear
about is do you mean me the
existence of the ordering?
In other words, it's the
fact that time is a parameter
in all of our physical
theories, is that fundamental?
Or do you mean is the orientation
of the past and the future fundamental?
And I think pretty
clearly in Carlo's story,
it's, I don't know what
his views on this are,
but it's perfectly comfortable with
thinking that time in the
first sense is fundamental,
but not comfortable at all with time
in the second sense
being fundamental, right?
But yeah, so that's, so
you were asking about,
were you asking about it
in the first sense or
the second sense Priya?
- I guess I was asking
about the first sense.
Yeah, because I mean, Carlo
has talked about theories
and theoretical ideas in which time
need not appear as a
parameter at all, right?
- Right, but this is, yeah, right.
So two separate questions.
One is a question about the orientation.
- Right.
- Let me say a word about that.
Just to put it out of the way.
The reason in the discussion
in quantum mechanics,
but I'm much committed, in fact,
I just have a paper out on that,
in which that the discussion about quantum
and non relativistic
quantum mechanics say,
it just like the classical one,
it doesn't change anything to
what we've been saying so far.
Maybe quantum mechanics is also
embodied into the time reversal.
In fact, I had a lot of
discussion with various people
with very detailed people arguing that
and we got three
wonderful referees report,
very, very detailed with a lot of,
which basically said that all three,
but we knew that already.
And I agree, I mean, in
spite of some discussion,
I think that as far as the
orientation of time is concerned
the appointment guide
doesn't change anything.
Now, the first issue says, Eric was saying
the existence of a parameter
that in terms of which you
order the event of the universe,
has not, I haven't touched any of that
in this discussion at all.
And I think it's a separate issue
because when we talk about thermodynamics,
we're always thinking in a context
in which we have a time parameter.
So we learned from generativity
that the world it's more complicated
than just a single time evolving, okay?
I mean, you can, one can
use a cosmological time
and cosmological time is an
average in a sense, it's not a
so it's definitely when
one goes to generativity
and even more than one
was the point of gravity,
one needs a wider notion of temporality,
which we don't gonna into it now.
And I am convinced that
we do not yet have a clean
or even a vague, in fact,
understanding of thermodynamics
in this wider context.
So in fact, I consider
one of the open problems
with fundamental science.
We really don't have a
generativity thermodynamics
not only in the quantum domain,
but even in the classical domain.
We have thermodynamics on
a given curve space time,
that was worked out by Tolman
back in the '50s I guess.
But the thermodynamics in a fully
thermodynamic to space-time, so to say,
it's still very much in here.
So asking questions about
what is the second law of dynamics?
What is entropy when we
fold in the possibility
of statistical distribution of geometries,
it's something which there's
very little clarity right now,
in my head like, and I
think in many people's head.
- Thank you, so--
- But in a sense that
it doesn't have related,
because if causation is fundamental,
which was the original thing,
and it plays a fundamental arrow of time,
that the times goes in which knows that
anything cannot be traced
to just microscopic
description of things.
Then we will be in trouble
to understand generativity
I think, to understand quantum gravity,
because there we need even
the Vegas possibility of thinking.
- So I just wanted to open
up now and Peter Morgan,
did you wanna ask your question?
- I can certainly, if
you can hear me that is,
I can put the comment
I've put up here that is,
can we use and the knowledge
of the transistors,
to which the whole point is,
that you have a control input
as well as the in and the out.
And in many ways--
- [Cecelia] Can I store or take it out?
- Sorry?
- Sorry there's just
some background, yeah.
- So it does feel as if
often we try to leverage
our position, we think to
ourselves, oh, well, if I do this
then I can have a million
pounds in my bank account
and that's better than
doing some other action
that will just result in a
dollar in our bank account.
And so the very smallest
of impulses is our brain,
results in a really
relatively large change.
And so you're always trying to leverage.
And in some ways, I mean,
there's the old sort of,
maps and maps and smaller maps
or all the way down so to speak,
but at least over a few scales.
So, okay, well, here I am, hello?
- Can I ask you, I you missed
one word because of the sound,
but there was a key word,
you started by saying, can
we use the analogy with?
- Transistors.
- Oh, transistors?
- Yes, so with three, and
really also in an analogy
was leverage in the simple mechanical way,
just that we always are working
to result in a bigger change
as a result of something small,
minds typically in the beginning,
when you have a sense
of an idea of forming
and then becoming
emotional of your muscles,
becoming emotion of something else.
So always getting bigger
and bigger and bigger.
And then some of those
things become actual traces.
And some of them just
disappear into nothing.
You think yourself, I'm
gonna make a big change
by making this intervention
and actually nothing happens.
And other times you think to
yourself, even make no change
by making this other
intervention, of course.
And sometimes that becomes
something huge, always--
- Was the idea that somehow
this ability to cascade small
into big is thermodynamic.
- Well in the sense that
anything, they're all flows
of energy and of chemicals.
So there's not just
after all thermodynamics,
is not just about energy,
it's also about chemical
potentials and so on.
And indeed one has a
different chemical potential
for every possible chemical
there is, which is enormous.
And so we will leverage on
something like a particular oil
or a particular chemicals
and benzene has a very
different value in society
than does our chloroform
or whatever it may be.
And we seek to change the flows
of all these things separately,
we try to separate the flow
of something that starts off
as a mixture of benzene and chloroform
as part of just fuel or whatever,
and straight out of the ground.
We try to separate that out
into different by fractionation,
whatever other chemical or physical means.
It always, it's some engineer somewhere
I had to told himself,
Hey, if I just do this
I can have this huge,
great effect on the world.
And my bank account is
better because of it.
But of whatever motivation, of course,
I mean you certainly don't
wanna say just dollars,
but at the same time, resources
of all different kinds
and the dollar, the
abstract dollar in a way
it has its own chemical potential.
It's something really quite complex.
Nonetheless is rooted in the
real world is not in gold.
So sorry, I've gone off.
- Yes, Peter, I think I
see what you're you're at.
And I think I buy the analogy
because somehow what you're saying,
we studied physics and we
started everything being linear.
So small things produce small things,
big things to big things.
And then of course,
as soon as we go to
more complicated things
we discovered that not
the way the world work.
The work is not linear at all.
So the big things that
evolved into nothing
and that there are small
things that has huge effect,
and the entire of our
system is based on this idea
that you have one pin that
the term is the two big ones,
which one is that?
And yes, that's exactly
the point, it seem to me.
So if you not only think
in terms of big and small,
but you think that the small
is what you did not control
and you did not know.
And the big is what you
see, then you see a decider,
something splitting the future
from a situation which of course
the physics of a transistor
is time reversal embarrassment obviously.
But if you fold in dissertation.
So the little model
that I had about traces,
it's like it as system, right?
Because I had some macroscopic pendula
interacting with the small little things
of which I did not have control.
And once in a while, this is the point,
I wasn't to sure about thermodynamics
is always toward the equilibrium
or we say, oh, there's no
equilibrium thermodynamics,
very complicated, but
there's this thing in between
when you have system separation
and both systems want
to go to equilibrium,
but you know there a long,
long thermalization time
which is part of the monies
we understand very well.
And here it's exactly the same situation,
because if the interaction
is a little, a rare,
once a hot particle excites
a macroscopic pendulum,
you have a small effect creating something
that enters into the part
that you call microscopic.
So for you have a trace, and
you can use something similar
to model deliberation, okay?
Because you don't know what is happening,
but you know the coming out of the result.
So it is leverage what's, in
the sense that you were saying
that create traces, a little
few photons into the camera
create a picture that
allows us to know whether,
Hitler existed or not existed
was in Vienna or in Berlin.
So I see the analogy and the key point
being that is scale
separation and nonlinearity,
and the big effect of small causes
that ground oldest phenomenology
that then we interpret
as a trace or a agency.
I don't know if one can
do more than this analogy
can use that more explicit,
this I don't know.
- Great, thanks, anyone
else from the audience
have any questions, please feel
free to type up in the chat
or let me know, and we can unmute and--
- Although I had one sort of
minor question from yesterday,
which was, I was interested in your claim
that all of our style's causes
have the time asymmetry that we associate
with our modern notion of cause,
I thought that was a
somewhat surprising claim
particularly about final causes.
Why do you think final causes
for Aristotle have the
ordinary time orientation?
- Because of that, it's
good that you raise that,
because my first thing
and I'll tell you how,
when I thought about that,
my first train of thought
was, wait a minute.
It's not true that the
cause precedes the effect.
We use final courses all the time.
- I mean, he calls them final causes
because precisely 'cause he thinks
that the thing at the
end of the temporal chain
is the cause.
- Yeah, I mean, that's Aristotle
notion of common causes,
but it's a notion that we
use is not the notion that,
I mean, he emphasizes it,
I put the cause for which
you put money in the bank
is for the education of your children.
So the causes in the future
is education of your children.
Not because I take the umbrella
is because tomorrow is gonna rain.
So it's, tomorrow's rain
because of my umbrella.
So we use the notion of final
causes all the time, right?
And then you say, okay so therefore,
causes are not time oriented.
And the final causes are just the reversal
of efficient causes in Aristotle language.
So efficient causes is when
I put the cause in the past.
And when I do the other way
around, it's a final causes
that causes the future,
but that's not true,
because final causes are
not the time reversal
of efficient causes at all.
There are different beasts,
completely different beasts.
So therefore the, and we can go in exactly
what are we sort of means by causal
'cause all what we mean,
like I was of course said,
so in other words both efficient causes
and the final causes have
either time orientation.
They both require to distinguish
the past or the future.
And of course, we usually
can retrace the fact
that what we usually do in our mentality,
we will trace the final
causes into efficient causes.
- But we do that, but of
course Aristotle didn't
Aristotle for final causes were
really fundamental causal
building blocks of the universe.
So Aristotle thought
there really was causation
from ends to beginnings with rethink
when you say, oh, I put the
money in my bank account.
So as to send my children to college,
we can reconstruct that.
So that it's really just
efficient cause right.
While it's really just that
you had the belief that
putting money in the bank would,
and if the belief that
causes the putting in money
and not the end, but Aristotle thought,
no, he the final causes
really do bring about
States of affairs.
- Oh yeah, sure, yeah.
So what I would argue is that
from our understanding of causes...
- Yeah okay.
- Time, no, yeah, kind of cause
the center is not on a very
it's really striking
because he was a biologist
as a scientist mostly.
And so he basically, there's
a page in his biology
which I find completely striking.
He says, look, you can think of causation
from the future in biology,
in evolutionary terms.
Because I had been in
Pedro class with his idea
of essentially of
Davinian selection, right?
The things we have, the
cats have the right number
of legs because those without
the right number of legs die,
because they cannot survive.
And Aristotle has a very
interesting point he said,
"That's a great idea but it does not work,
because we don't see cats
being born with an
average number of legs."
I can talks about our cows.
If we saw that we would believe that,
but no they're already
born, but then he says,
but there are seeds.
So he sort of suggesting
it could happen that
not the individual cats, but
the entire family of cats
survive because of natural selection.
So it's just there and there's
okay, now I'm gonna say
and he says, well, but I'm
not doing history here.
I'm doing the world as it is.
And to understand the world
as it is final causes work.
So it's, Aristotle is--
- He's almost there, yes.
- Right.
- Yes.
- Great I think we have
some questions in the chat.
Do you wanna--
- Yeah, so I think Gary?
- [Gary] Yes, does your theory imply
and completely determine
universe as Aristotle believed?
- Good, no, the answer is no.
First of all, I hesitate to say
what I presented as my theory.
I think I put a little
couple of pieces in a puzzle,
which is a number of ideas
most of which are not mine,
but I try to do then
have an overall picture
including the little pieces I added there,
and I presented it in the
context of classical mechanics,
most thing which you can
think that the municipally
but I think that that's obviously wrong
because the world seems
to be non-deterministic
with a lot of caveat and the proper sense
because of quantum mechanics.
So the present, what we
can know about the present
does not determine the future.
But I believe that nothing changes
and everything can be said
that just with more complicated language,
in terms of probabilities.
At the same step, I
mean, I talk about humor
and if it Lewis reformulating
human colorization
in probabilistic terms,
I think it can be done
exactly the same thing
in a more elaborated way.
So there is no specific
roles for determinism
in anything I said.
But of course it's not
undetermined toward the future,
is undetermined is
equally toward the future
or toward the past.
So it's not that by itself
undetermined is helps us at all
to understand the orientation of time,
and the nature of the causation.
- [Gary] Okay.
- Not everybody agrees with them.
If it was this idea
because some people think
that quantum mechanics is
naturally sort of probability
toward the future, but I don't
see any evidence of that.
Quantum mechanics it's
naturally interpreted
in a union sense.
Is there a regularities?
These regularities are not
strict are probably sneak,
but they are regularities.
And if I look at regularities
their time reversal variant.
- Thank you, next we have
Tibor, who has a question.
- [Tibor] Thank you, can you hear me?
- Yes.
- [Tibor] Thank you, excellent.
Two thoughts that I've had prompted
by what you Carlo and
Eric had been saying.
One of them is that it occurs
to me that quantum mechanics
may not be a theory on
the ultimately fundamental
basic level on that elementary scale.
It is itself a theory, perhaps
on some emergence scale
and the world being a complex system
which I think we all agree
means that the uncertainties
the unpredictabilities, the approximations
that Carlo was talking about,
arise as a result of the complexity
of this macroscopic scale,
this sort of intermediate
macroscopic scale
which is a quantum scale
rather than the world being
fundamentally in deterministic.
And maybe it's possible
to accommodate the idea
that the world is deterministic,
at the basic fundamental elementary scale,
but it is indeterministic
or at least indeterminable
on some intermediate macroscopic scale
which is the quantum scale.
And then there's another
even greater scale,
which is of course to scout where we live.
Now, if that's the
case, if that's possible
that's a plausible idea.
What I'd like to ask is,
is it impossible to invoke
the principle of least action
as a characterization of
causation on the elementary scale
on that very lowest bottom scale,
where in a Borden and perhaps
Thomas Hobbes in kind of sense
things happen because they
can interactions arise
just because they interact
the conservation laws hold
and everything seems to work
out what their bottom scale
and in a purely deterministic way.
And then they may be an ordering by that
whether there's temporal direction or not.
I don't think that matters at that scale.
All of that arises when we
move to a somewhat higher level
where we start talking
about quantum mechanics,
if we make that distinction,
if we try and characterize
quantum mechanics
as being emergent as perhaps
I think it's Steven ATLA
at Princeton, who does that,
he thinks the quantum mechanics
is an emergent system.
If we characterize it that way,
does that help us to understand causation
at different levels?
We have a causation at
the fundamental level
which is just a principle of least action.
And we have a different notion
of causation in the quantum scale.
- Let me try to listen precisely
to the various point named.
The first one, the first
point you made is that
could quantum mechanics be a manifestation
of an underlying level
where there is no one
undetermined is, the
answer is yes, absolutely.
And in fact, we know, not
one but more than one theory
where that realizes that one
is a pilot, wait, a theory.
It's a perfectly deterministic
sort of metaphysically
classical theory with equations of motions
and no indeterminism whatsoever.
Another ways of doing the same thing
is also many worlds interpretation
of quantum mechanics
because that also deterministic
is just the Schrodinger
equation for the real thing
being the wave function.
And then a more complicated story,
connecting that to the observations of...
People don't like these options
not because they are incoherent or wrong,
it's just because I
don't like these options
because they don't seem to teach us more
than what what mechanics teaches us,
namely, there is this
invisible part of the world
which we don't have access
according to the same theory
is outside our reach.
We just cannot know it.
So they facto we have the still the same
impossibility to predict
the past and the future
in the many worlds
because we're in a branch
and we don't know about the other branches
and so on and so forth.
We don't know which branch
we are more precise.
So the first part is yes.
I mean, we could interpret
quantum mechanics this way
but then you say, would that help us
to understand something
about causation better?
I don't think so, because the question
that was being debated is the
time direction of causation
and all those theories are
time reversal invariant.
They don't distinguish
that from the future
in the proper sense.
So even if we take quantum
mechanics and put it in
and imagine that there
is actually real whatever
underlying level in which
there is as you said,
a principle of least actual working,
we're back to square one,
namely we have a time
reversal invariant fundamental
description of what happens
and no notion of causation
time-oriented causation.
- [Tibor] Okay, but
that's, I understand that,
I think it was Eric who said that
or maybe you said it yesterday,
that the time directional is
itself an emerging property
at the bottom level there
is time reversal symmetry.
- Yeah.
- [Tibor] And I agree
there wouldn't be any law
that we made up using the
principle of least action
at the bottom level would
be time reversal symmetric.
It's only at the emergent level
when we start getting feedback
and the more complex systems
that the the asymmetry emerges.
So we can understand causation at the time
symmetric fundamental level
as just an implementation
of interactions of just one thing
happening after another
one thing causing another,
we can have causation just
as least actions and least interactions.
We can have causation at that level.
And causation would still be describable
using time symmetrical laws,
perhaps even despite the fact
that the world itself
is not time symmetric.
It may be the case at the time
there is a fundamental direction of time
that there is a case the way
in every interaction there's
a before and then after
that it may be possible that exists
but it is described because
all the actions are primitive,
all the interactions are primitive.
Every interaction at
that level is describable
using time symmetric laws.
So maybe that our description of the world
can be time symmetrical as a law.
And our physics can be time
symmetrical on that scale.
And we can impose a time
symmetrical description
on something which is perhaps
really time asymmetrical.
I dunno, I don't think
it makes a difference
whether the world is time
symmetric or time asymmetrical.
And I'm talking about what
the world perhaps "Really" is.
I'm talking about the ontology here.
It may be time asymmetric,
it may be time symmetric,
but we can describe both of these
at that fundamental level
with time symmetric laws,
because at times symmetrical laws
cover applying both directions.
It's like the billiard balls on the table,
you can just, there is
a case that the balls
were in one place and
then you play the game
and the balls end up in another place.
And you can say there's a
time asymmetry about that.
But at every interaction, every
collision between two balls
you can describe it using
time symmetric laws.
So I'm just wondering if it's not possible
for us to impose time symmetry
or to expect time symmetry
even patch when there isn't any?
- I think a philosophy should
address this better than me,
but let me add a statistic.
What would it mean to say
that there is a fundamental
real time asymmetry,
if we cannot describe it,
we cannot perceive it,
we cannot observe it.
We cannot, if it is invisible,
because everything we
have experience about
obeys time symmetric laws.
So what's the point of saying, I mean
it wouldn't be like, yeah, I
mean, everything is possible.
There could be, angels dancing on dragons
in a in a parallel
universe, it's possible,
but what's the point.
That's not, what we have access to.
- [Tibor] That's true, I guess for me,
the point is simply trying to understand
what I mean by causation
and assuming the time symmetric
world is no less visible
is no less observable than
a time asymmetric one.
The world that you described
and saying the world
is fundamentally time symmetrical.
Well, we can observe that either.
So we don't gain anything
from any of these things
other than conceptually,
other than as a tool
for understanding what
we're talking about.
I think both of us, or all of
us are in theoretical physics.
We're all talking about a
world that no one can observe.
We're looking for fundamental
ways of modeling the world
out of what we produce that
derivative around models
can predict or describe
the macroscopic world
that we experience.
(indistinct)
- There's a fair amount
of sense of what the world
is obviously time asymmetric, right?
I mean, it's, as the song says
starts in a hot dense state,
and it's gonna end in antsy,
just sit her space.
So and it's fundamentally asymmetric
in various features in
our experience, right?
But the question is just,
I take it the question is
just the puzzle arises because
at certain levels of description, namely,
particularly the macroscopic ones
that are relevant to our experience.
We see repeated patterns that
are time-based symmetric.
There's a kind of, it
seems as though there are
macroscopic laws that are
themselves time asymmetric
and the puzzle is you get asymmetric laws
out of merely an asymmetry
in the initial conditions
there's manifestly in asymmetry
the initial conditions
at every level of description, right?
What's puzzling is that you can leverage,
and this is what's so
brilliant and fascinating
and would be just wonderful
if the all details came together.
And I'm sort of always on the fence
about whether I think
it's happening or not,
but what would be amazing,
would be to be able to show that this one
asymmetry merely in
the initial conditions,
getting an able to give rise
to all of these asymmetric patterns,
not just that like the
past it's differently
of course, the past and
the future like that.
It's different in this repeated
way that that undergirds
all of these seemingly law life
asymmetric features, right?
The eggs never, it's not just
that there's more broken eggs
on the future than there are in the past.
If the eggs never unbreak, right?
How can that come from just an asymmetry
in the initial conditions?
That seems like a magic trick,
but it's one that people like Carlo
are trying to try to pull off
to show that it actually can go.
I think, that's what's going on here.
It's not about whether there is
or isn't an asymmetry or whatever.
It's about whether an asymmetry
in nearly the initial
conditions can give rise
to all these beautiful
persistent law-like pattern
asymmetries in our ordinary experience.
- So I think we have a
lot of questions piling up
in the chat.
So I'd like us to move on to Rory.
Did you wanna ask your question please?
- [Rory] Yeah thanks,
so my question is about
just from the organizational side
of going into it to Lyman in
his discourse on metaphysics
makes an argument for a world
where God knows the future
and an argument that a kind
of agency or free will exists.
And so in order to do that,
he makes a distinction
between necessary proof
which logically the opposite is impossible
and certain truths or certain events.
And so certain events he says
are necessary X hypothesis
which is after they happen.
And so based on that, he
says that at the moment
in which we exist,
the past is made up of all necessary trues
because they're X hypotheses
that the necessary trues
and the contingent certain
truths are now all necessary.
But in the future among possibilities
there are a limited
number of possibilities
because of the necessary
truth, which can be otherwise.
But then one way things
will happen is certain
because they can't happen more
than one way in his organization.
So, is that a good, is that
a bad notion or are there,
what problems are there
maybe with that framework?
And then also by that empirical
it's also an argument against
a determinism in a way
because looking at the
past and seeing a cost
there's a cost for every possible event.
So it could be a different way.
And you would also find a cause,
So finding causes for the present
doesn't mean that the future
can only go a long way.
- I haven't started live needs
on a few wheels essentially.
And the distinction between
a logical and certain.
So I don't know, I
should think about that.
I'm possible because of course the problem
obviously comes in that period, right?
Spinoza is debating with the same thing
which can bring a different outcome
but the problem is much
older, it has been debated
for all the middle
European middle ages right?
They, God knows the future.
What do you next question is that,
so what does it mean we are free?
I mean, it's already in the mind of God
what's gonna happen in next.
And that's exactly the problem.
It's exactly the same
problem of determinism.
So, I'm trying to navigate out of that.
It seems to me that the
specific solution that,
on which we reasonably
work is one of Spinoza
not one of livelihoods, namely
we are confusing levels of description
in which we know more
and we know a little,
microphysics and microphysics
or Spinoza terminology.
We know what we wish, but
we don't know the causes
of what's because it's not
in the sense that we see now
that the causes of the
bring us to wish one thing
of the other thing to decide
one thing and another thing.
So the problem only comes
if we take the perfectly legitimate notion
of free will and decision and an agency
and arbitration and deliberation,
which are all good ways
of describing the world
and we will interpret them metaphysically
as denial to possible
forget quantum mechanics
the possible underlying determinism.
And we shouldn't, it's like now,
it's a common mistake that
I think we do constantly
confuses our mind like when we...
I prefer the way a
metaphor for saying that,
if we think the sunset is
the sun diving in the ocean
when we discovered that
the sun just stays there
and the earth is spinning,
It doesn't mean that
there's no sunset anymore.
There's still a sunset.
It's just a sunset, this
is not what we thought,
but it has all the properties
that we wanted before.
So if we discovered that these
determinants in the world
it doesn't mean that
there is no free will.
It just means that free
will is another thing
that what we thought before.
- [Rory] Gotcha, I appreciate it.
Is there something, sorry.
- Great, so I guess the next question
we have from Seungel Lee.
- [Seungel] Yeah, thank
you, thank you very much
for both of you.
So my question is how exactly we can get
the causal asymmetry from
the entropy asymmetric.
I think the claim that we
cannot influence the past
is if it's true at all
then would be true as a matter
of physical necessity, right?
It's not like it's terribly
difficult to influence the past,
but it's just impossible to do so,
if the claim is true at all,
but the the entropy asymmetry
is probabilistic in nature.
So I wonder how this
streak causal asymmetry,
it could arise from the probabilistic
statistical and symmetric.
The only way I can make sense
of this reductive explanation
for me, is to think of
causation as an epistemic
sort of notion.
I think Eric mentioned this briefly
something close to this,
but so changing the past
would amount to changing our
information about the past
or what we believe about the
past or something like that
that ended up to be very
difficult to do change the past
but wouldn't be impossible per se.
So is that the way we
should understand possession
as it is supposed to be
reduced to entropy arrow?
Or is there something else?
- Can I jump out on this?
- Yes.
- Sure.
- Yeah, so, sorry, I think it's important,
or I think it's important to remember
the following thing here about
causation and about agency
and about changing the
future and changing the past.
And I'm gonna talk as if we live
in a perfectly ordinary classical world
but I don't think quantum
mechanics or relativity
or anything changes these.
We cannot in the ordinary physical sense,
we cannot change either the
past or the future, right?
Once the universe has
its initial conditions
and it has its laws, it will
evolve as it will evolve.
So the future is in that
sense, in terms of like
in terms of the fundamental
physical description
of the world, the future is
just as fixed as the past, okay?
So when we talk about our
ability to change the future
but our inability to change the past,
we got to be quite subtle
about what we mean by that.
We don't wanna get it's like,
it's exactly like the sunset thing, right?
I mean, there's still gonna be a sunset
but it's not gonna be
what we thought it was
in the fourth century
or something like that,
it's gonna have to be something
that respects the fact.
I mean, at least if
you're at all in any kind
of sympathy with the way
I think about the world,
it's gonna have to respect the fact
that what's going on in our minds
when we think about deliberating,
about how we wanna bring
about changes in the future
has to be consistent with,
this is what the law
was called compatiblism,
has to be compatible
with the understanding
that this is all at the microscopic level
at the level of physical
law, this is all unfolding
in a way that's completely
oblivious to my existence.
And it doesn't care one way
to my, about my deliberations.
So when we talk about the
inability to change the past,
but the ability to change the future,
we gotta be really subtle
about what that exactly means
and the best, Carlo might
have a slightly different way
of characterizing it than I do,
but the way I like to think about this.
You've got to think about
what exactly is going on
in deliberation and about why
it is that in deliberation
we treat the future as open, right?
It's not in any deep sense
that the future really is
more open than the past,
it's that there's something
about the nature of our agency,
that it makes sense to
treat the future as open.
And if you don't, I think
characterize the problem that way
you're gonna give yourself fits
because you're gonna
start thinking that, like,
how gee what do you mean?
Like, if you make it seem unlikely
that I could change the
past, that seems wrong.
'Cause it seems like it's necessarily,
no, you can't change that,
for talking about things in terms
of what are necessary
truths even physical law
can change the future or the
past when I order, right?
If we're talking about what underpins my,
when I deliberate that I
treat the future as open,
and then the fact that probabilism
that that's inherent in
Cisco cast comes into it
might seem less positive
than you made that to be
when you were treating
it as if it's the past
and the future that are
really can be influenced
by me in a deep metaphysical
sense or something like that.
- No, point very well taken Eric, yeah.
- Yeah, this is really good.
That's a great answer.
I think it's I agree with it.
Can I touch one thing I'm trying to...
can I remember from one of the questions,
the second law of thermodynamics
is not an exact law.
It's a probabilistic law.
I mean, we can find a
situation where it is.
And in fact, we do find
situations in the laboratory
when you have a few number of things
in which we violate what we would think
the law thermodynamics would say
if we took it too seriously.
And now the question is, aha,
if we can affect the future not the past,
because of the psychological dynamics.
And since it's psychological
makes approximative,
then the fact that we
can affect the future,
not the past, it's also proximity.
So we may a little bit
affect the past as well.
That's the question.
And I think Eric answer is perfectly now,
when you go to the regime
where the cycle of dynamic
does not hold which is a huge
number of degrees of freedom
is not that now you can affect
the past and also the future
is that the meaning of affecting loses,
doesn't mean anything anymore.
The meaning of I'm capable of fact.
And if it's something
that has meaning only
in terms of notions where
the psychological holds.
- [Seungil] Thank you, that
was very clear, thank you.
- Yep, so I read out two comments
before we close with the final question.
So Sudan Lakshmi has a comment about
people with schizophrenia
are known to have
an abnormal sense of agency
and looking at their experiences
has been a very fruitful way to think
about the concept of agency itself.
The main way in which
their sense of agency
seems different from the standard one
has to do with where to draw
the line between an agent
and the rest of the system
sort of partitioning the world, right?
How do you partition the world?
And often people with
schizophrenia attribute the actions
of other agents or the
behavior of the system itself
to themselves, or the other way around.
So it's kind of a partitioning
error if you will, right?
So I, and she's just wondering
if people have looked at
whether the sense of agency
that people with schizophrenia have
includes the notion of
temporarily symmetry.
Is there some clue to
temporal asymmetry there
because of this kind
of partitioning error?
And I thought it was a
very interesting comment,
and if you guys had any thoughts on it,
it will be wonderful to hear.
- Well that is super interesting.
It's, I mean, a lot of, as I, I mean
I think maybe this is a
little bit of a difference
between me and Carlo.
I really do tend to think
of that third asymmetry
in terms of our psychological
properties, right?
Of how we think about our agency.
And so, yeah, I think
it'd be really interesting
to look at how other
people, I suspect that,
two things I sort of mildly
suspect that schizophrenia
is don't have any differences with respect
to the temporary asymmetry
of the notion agency.
I strongly suspect that even if they do
the literature hasn't noticed this
because it doesn't seem
like the kind of thing
that the relevant people
would pay attention to
but I don't know.
- Yeah, so there's another, thank you.
There's another comment,
which is from, Ferdoz
always a friend of mine and he said,
he's kind of curious why we
have not touched on Kant at all.
And we have discussed
Hume, Spinoza, Aristotle.
Well, the entire Pantheon
really enlighten it
but not Kant and the synthetic
April, right judgments.
And it's all--
- Kant think cause are just in your head.
They're not in the world, so.
- Yeah.
- Why would we hate them that
if you wanna know what the
origin of the causal asymmetry
as for Kant is, that's we impose it.
- Yeah, Carlo, did you wanna step in
and say something or I can then move?
- No, I mean, let me say
something a bit naive.
Of course you can be a Kant
and of course it's fine.
And of course it's, but
then we are naturalists.
So the my head in which
the apriori are sitting,
we want to, I mean,
it's just this false apriori of knowledge.
You want to reinterpret
them as actual, natural,
the subject it's part of
nature in my philosophy.
So it's fine Kant, but there's
just a half of the story.
I want to know the
other half of the story.
- Yeah, it's not that
big story, right, yes.
So, okay, so I think we
should, since it's getting on
will close with the final
question from Cecilia,
and her question is hypothetically,
let's say the past at the
macro scale can change
in accordance with the new future chosen
by an agent from within the present moment
like the light code model
and say this new correlation
was an unconscious choice
by said agent then records
of its previous past
would exist as memories
perhaps traces also exist in
three dimensions as evidence.
Seeing as the agent is as Carlo beliefs,
part of nature, nature
would thus grant the agent's
conscious choice to hold
their memories as true
while also granting its unconscious choice
for a new past or future correlation.
Would this harmonious system grant both
of the agents requests
or would there be a dilemma?
What could appear in the present moment
to fulfill its desire
while staying within the
agent's realm of expectation?
Interesting hypothetical--
- I don't know, it's too complicated.
- Yeah, its a complicated--
- Well we need to think of that,
but it could be a novel, right?
It's a science fiction novel
of this story, I don't know.
I'm not capable to answer.
I don't know if Eric can that,
you follow the story did you?
- No.
- Okay, so great, I guess we wrap up here.
Thank you, Eric and Carlo
for a wonderful discussion
and for engaging this very
sort of subtle nuanced
complicated material and
clarifying things for us
and thank you to everyone who attended
and for all the wonderful questions.
So very, very delighted.
And we hope that you will all participate
in this continuing series.
And I just want to mention
that the recording of yesterday's talk
and today's conversation
will both be available within a week.
So if you want to listen to it again
or pass the word and share it, please do.
So, thank you once again, Eric and Carlo
for sharing this a Saturday
afternoon without us.
- Thanks for having us.
- Yeah, that was a total treat,
really looking forward to this
continuance with patients.
- Pretty much present its extra
ordinary interesting for me,
thank you, Eric, I think I'm
gonna meditate on the points
that you raised especially the
relevance of the complexity
of the higher level of the agency role.
And so I look forward for the
continuation of discussions.
- Yeah, thank you, thanks everyone, bye.
Have a lovely rest of the weekend.